[Musique]
ce
grégory tu regarde souvent la télévision
oui et qu'est-ce que tu regarde à la
télévision
les dessins animés et films les théâtres
c'est tout c'est déjà pas mal
et toi lester les feuilletons mois les
westerns et les animaux il fut enfin et
les émissions des jeux moi j'aime bien
les westerns les policiers et les
dessins animés aussi à moi je trouve à
paris par exemple les émissions du
mercredi après-midi parce qu'elles sont
un peu bidon puis quand on veut laisser
parler les enfants et bien là la plupart
du temps il use le micro quand il veut
comme ça au moment où il commence à
parler mes films préférés ce sont mes
films d'événements dont elle demande
donc à se dérouler par hasard ça c'est
quelque chose qui je veux regarder si tu
aimerais belmondo oui
comme un film c'est le film de la même
visite alors évidemment oui
comment il fait
et qui ses parents à 28 ans qui séparent
en a mais j'aimerais bien comme page des
films comme crin blanc quelque chose
comme ça le mardi soir pour les enfants
parce que sinon nous samedi soir et les
chansons il ya des choses mais pas crime
pour enfants je regrette qu'on passe pas
plus souvent par exemple définitif coop
comme les oiseaux des films de genre
très spectaculaire des films qui sont
comme ça qui ne sont pas terrorisant ben
je crois que nous défendons notre âge on
peut s'il portait encore les oiseaux
tu as quel âge moi j'ai 11 ans lui je
crois que c'est plus jeune il a pas eu
peur du tout il ya un autre film
d'hitchcock la quittes assez amusant je
crois ses compos de famille qui vient
juste de sortir
bon c'est peut-être un petit peu violent
c'est peut être interdit au moins de 13
ans mais comparé au film qui nous passe
pour enfants tous les soirs à la
télévision qui sont d'une violence
beaucoup plus forte
je tourne je comprends pas pourquoi ils
nous interdisent d'entrer dans un film
beaucoup moins violent mais est ce que
tu crois que le film qui passe le soir à
la télévision sont des films pour
enfants
ben est la plupart du temps non parce
que nous parents évidemment qu'on sait
pour adultes ils nous permettent pas
mais qu'on sait pour adultes et
adolescents déjà et qui sont plus
indulgents et ils nous permettent mais
aussi on m'a vraiment alors par exemple
hi-fi demande 13 ans la moitié des films
dont on pourra les voir nous enfin mario
quintin d'alcool pas comment j'ai fait
non pas écolo nous sommes dit mercredi
n'a pas école le mercredi
et quand tu quand tu vas à l'école de
l'ordre mac à quelle heure jusqu'à
quelle heure tu regarde la télévision
c'est à dire 10h 10h30 et tu as quel âge
n'était pas fatigué le lendemain matin
[Musique]
vienne la chance parce que moi que je me
couche à vis de lui je suis fâché y en a
bon
[Musique]